could you measure the x y and z
individually or is that not an option
there's two problems with that one is
for the big change is due to the
distance up and down
below you which primarily will affect
the z-axis at least when you're flat you
just end up having to solve exactly the
same problem for z access what this does
is it just it basically just tweaks each
of the weights of the x y and z axis
until it sees a nice flat curve
in the kind of previous points
now
there is a kind of classic signal
processing approach to this problem
which would be to use a low-pass filter
if you're trying to solve a problem
we're trying to solve here which is find
position in a swimming pool you want to
find what the position is now
and with a low-pass filter it's got a
kind of inherent delay and
to actually build a low-pass filter that
filters out things that are on the order
of kind of seconds so a stroke you're
typically doing sort of one stroke so
one stroke per second or so
you actually your actually low pass
filter is going to give you a sort of
two or three second delay
which um
for a fast swimmer that's got from 10
meters or something you know on a push
off or a dive that's got them a long way
so you can't really use classic signal
processing approach so this is why we
use this kind of approach which
basically kind of
shuffles each one it's a it's a kind of
gradient descent it shuffles each weight
and it says did that make it better or
worse
and if it makes it better it accepts it
smartphones have accelerometers in don't
know presumably you could sync these up
and work out what orientation the phone
is so
yeah you can do that the problem i found
when i was doing that is for the timing
of sensors on phones or at least
the timing of sensors on the model of
phone i had
was
not the same so the magnetometer was
sending out signals a different time to
the accelerometer
and
when you put that into the
algorithm to kind of correct for this
it just didn't work because you could
never get them synchronized and i think
and
neither neither sensor was sending
things that bang on 200 times a second
or something they're all kind of a bit
stuttery and
it just didn't work correcting it that
way just not precise enough presumably
yeah the chipped in an accelerometer
chip that's in a smartphone that'll cost
sort of one dollar or something you know
very little amount of money the key
thing to understand with this is
where the error is so the error is in
when you're taking the magnitude you've
got an x and a y and a z and you know
that those are off by a little bit
initially you record um you record the
kind of signature of the pool i've
called it the shape that paul
gives out if you swam flat across it
that's not really used in a correction
algorithm that's only used for matching
where you are in the pool when i am kind
of filtering out the noise here the
noise that's from side to side movement
all i'm actually using is the previous i
think four seconds of swimming the
reason for that is that this noise is
very much dependent on when you when you
actually did each stroke
so um
you can't really filter it out purely
using vm pull signature or using any
kind of known things about the error in
the magnetometer and stuff so
there are
quite a lot of algorithms for correcting
for error in magnetometers
but the problem with those is they all
assume that the source of the error is
static and you're trying to correct for
a static source of error whereas
what we're trying to do really is detect
a particular source of error which
changes all the time so the effect of it
changes over time so i mean all these
kind of classic algorithms for doing it
just don't work when you stick for stick
someone in a swimming pool where there's
loads of magnetic error around so on
these two graphs here you can see here
is the
before graph this is showing all the
magnetic error and this actually has
quite a bad case of magnetic error so
really
big and
actually once you've processed that out
it actually takes the most smooth
weighting of all these sensors and here
you can see this is a really smooth
graph here you can really see the shape
of the pool signature which i showed
before in that graph and that's from a
real swimmer that's actually from me
swimming along the pulse um so that's
the corrected it's not just a flat
signature of the pool that's the
corrected signature that
was recorded from me swimming along
there's the basic things that you can do
which
people will obviously want like
timing swimming and stuff like that
which
is very easy but then you can do much
more complex feedback so
we've actually sort of started thinking
a bit about using um music which is
actually
controlled by the swimming so it kind of
responds to how you're swimming
and perhaps responds to kind of a rhythm
of your swimming and the kind of nature
of your swimming how good your swimming
is and looking at can you measure things
like that and can you
once you have measured them can you
actually kind of
give people useful responses
and is that i mean would that be all
sorts of different possibilities not
just uh rhythm of the music you know
tempo of the music would that be kind of
the style or the melody would you get
sad music if you're not doing so well
if you've got a smartphone attached to
you
and you have some way of
getting audio to your ears you you know
you've got waterproof headphones on or
you've got
some way of getting kind of rhythm to
you through vibrations
um
you've got a really powerful computing
device so yeah you can do things that
you can really do things that respond to
people in very nuanced and new ways the
focus now is taking this kind of
technology we've built this technology
for magnetic sensing i've also built
some stuff to do with as well as sensing
the fact that someone sent doing a
stroke so saying you are you did one
pull a front call or you did one
stroke
one stroke cycle of breaststroke um
it's also looking at how you did that so
how well you did that or
what particular kind of stylistic
elements of that there are because
people swim in very different ways
and some of them are more or less
efficient than others